we are asked what is a reasonable
estimate for the limit of g of x as x
approaches 3. so what we have here in
blue this is the graph of y is equal to
g of x and we want to think about what
is the limit as x approaches 3. so this
is x equals 3 here so what you need to
do is think about what is the limit of
this function as we approach 3 from the
left and we're also going to think about
what is the limit of this function what
does it appear to be from the graph as
we approach this value from the right
and if it looks like we're approaching
the same value then that would be a
reasonable estimate for the limit and
the reason why they say reasonable
estimate is because we're going to do it
by inspection we don't have a lot more
information about the graph to know for
sure but from the graph we can come up
with a reasonable estimate so pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
on your own
all right so let's think about it
let's think about it in two parts let's
think about approaching x equals three
or let's think about the limit as x
approaches three from
the left as we approach x equals three
from the left so as we approach x equals
three from the left our graph
seems to be
our graph seems to if i just eyeball it
seems to be approaching the value 4. so
from the left it looks like
we are approaching 4.
approaching or let me write it this way
g of x approaching 4.
g of x
approaching
4 as
x approaches 3
from the left
now let's think about it from the right
as x approaches 3 from the right what
does it look like g of x is approaching
well it looks like g of x is approaching
negative 3 as x approaches 3 from the
right
so i could say g of x
approaching
negative 3
as x approaches 3 from
the right
and so we have two different values here
when we approach from the left it looks
like g of x is approaching 4 and when we
approach from the right it looks like g
of x is approaching negative 3.
and so because of that we would say that
this limit right over here it's
reasonable to say that this limit
doesn't exist
so i'll write does
not
exist
based on looking at this graph right
over here and a good clue that it won't
exist is the x value where we're trying
to find the limit at you see this jump
in the graph right over here it is
discontinuous it jumps from one value to
another which is a good clue that the
limit might not exist here